hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
Monday
July 17
2023. what's going on Hawaii
how's things in your neck of the woods
there
uh podcast is a little late I got I got
confused
I got so confused this weekend because
usually if I do two
if I'm working two nights it's either
Thursday Friday or Friday Saturday
however
this weekend it was Saturday Sunday
which was really weird so all day
yesterday I was feeling like it was
Saturday then I woke up this morning
and I got on the plane I was like wait a
minute it's [__] Monday
I owe the good people
of the [__]
podcast world the goddamn podcast so my
apologies
for being late
you know am I right am I reminding you
of some [__] person you're sick of in
your life oh I miss you man I'm sorry
I'm late well listen you know I left my
wallet at my house I'm oh listen you
know why yeah
do you have accidentally do something
for everybody else you [__] [__]
um
anyway sorry I'm getting away from that
air conditioner it was a little loud
there
um
I want to thank everybody who came out
this weekend
all right I had an incredible show
Saturday night and Sunday night uh
two of my favorite shows of the year
I mean I was on stage I didn't even feel
like I was doing my ACT I was just
talking it was just flowing through me
and I really feel it was the uh the
energy that the people were bringing so
thank you so much and part of it might
have been the coffee I had got to give a
shout out
I was in Tacoma
and I was on the road with uh Nate Craig
and Bianca Christoval and they both
[__] killed it
and we had you know just a great time
hanging out and I had I think Nate
Googled the coffee and we ended up
trying this place Manifesto coffee
which was just out of this [__] world
I came back the next day to get some
more was [__] delicious I'll tell you
this one somebody makes an espresso
shout out to Luis by the way
the owner was talking all about coffee
was just you know neck deep and Coffee
Talk the guy was just all about it man
um
wasn't going to say he uh the way they
do it anytime I go to a coffee shop if
they have like an espresso
and they give you that little shot of
[__] seltzer water after it to
cleanse your palate
you know the little I know about coffee
I'm like okay I these people
these people are not [__] around
right
I feel like that's the equivalent
when you fly first class and they come
around with that hot washcloth
which you're supposed to just wipe your
hands off
but Americans we always wipe our face
too but then people made fun of us on
the internet I think we finally stopped
doing that because I noticed everybody
else stopped doing it like I thought
that's what you're supposed to do I
thought this was uh
you know wake myself I was always doing
that I was washing my goddamn face with
it
um
anyway
had an amazing time in Tacoma
I got uh
oh man I got I have I have a couple of
killer bits that are just topical
and now that this [__] business has
shut down everybody's on strike
which by the way can you believe that
[__] [__] I don't know who said it
some [__]
douche said we're not going to negotiate
with writers until they lose start
losing their apartments and their houses
just did I say that on the last but I
still cannot [__] get over that you
can publicly say something like that
you know during these unbelievably
sensitive times you can't even call a
fat [__] a fat [__] anymore and this guy
can say I mean that is like some [__]
right out of like a [__] superhero
like Lex Luthor would say some [__] like
that
ah no one cares
that is the funny thing about being in
this business is everybody around the
country seems to [__] hate Hollywood
I think everyone out here is a bunch of
[__] until you have a hurricane or a
flood and then you're like we need help
and then we always show up with our tap
dancing shoes and our little top hats
and a cane we do a little dance for you
and you then you say thank you so much
we appreciate it and the second the
water drains out of your basements what
do you guys ah [__] those [__]
pedophile lip [__] pieces of [__]
it's really a toxic relationship
um anyway
I hope they're not going to do what you
know they're gonna I hope they just you
know
just pay the [__] writers
just [__] pay them you [__] um
anyway
I'd want an even bigger house so I could
get some more horse
um
then we went up to Edmonton that was my
that was my um
my insight information on what the
strike is all about
um then we went up to Edmonton
and it looked like the day after the end
of the world they have wildfires up
there once again you know nobody doing
[__] about it nobody gives a [__] people
that can actually do something about it
nobody gives a [__] you know they
already have they're already hooked up
with a lifetime supply of [__] coffee
beans and a little [__] bed under the
mountain wherever these people are going
to go in the spaceship
when it's all used up
that's my theory
they're gonna be and then then Netflix
is going to be watching us eat each
other or bursting into flames
um sorry
I apologize
um
but anyway the show in Edmonton I'm not
gonna lie to you I showed up
it was 10 000 people outside in a park
the sun's still out even though it was
night because we're up you know Way
north of the equator
and um
it was still light out and there was all
you know this Haze because of the
wildfires
and I was just looking at this [__]
going like did my agent book me
[__] 31s in 31 years of my career to
do stand up in a [__] Park I used to
get gigs like this eight months into my
career and I was like this is gonna be a
hell gig
these people are going to be [__]
wasted they're not going to be listening
and I was 100 wrong
it's one of the best crowds I ever
performed to they were sitting there
they were listening they were laughing
it was
it boggled my mind how great it was
like 10 times during the amount of time
I was up there I kept thinking how is
this so good
everything is working against what is
happening right now yet it is all
working it was fantastic and uh I also
I hit the gym every single day
the green shirt diet
if you're having problems going to the
gym I have a solution
there's a documentary on Netflix
although I feel like a [__] [__]
telling me to go to a streaming service
with when none of these [__] want to
pay anybody
um
I was watching that Arnold
Schwarzenegger uh documentary
and uh oh my God
episode two of that thing
was one of the funniest [__] stories
dude this guy he just didn't give a [__]
he went from a bodybuilder he wants to
be an actor and somehow
he starts buying real estate because he
heard it was a good investment he was
like I became a millionaire before I
even I even you know tried to act so
then I didn't have to do the [__]
parts
you know my agents they wanted me to do
smaller parts be a character actor [__]
[__] I want to be the star I want to
be the lead right that was his [__]
attitude
and everyone was telling me was too big
and he had a [__] exit so he somehow
gets a meeting with this guy who's made
like 500 [__] movies
he walks in there with his agent
and I guess the guy was a little fella
and he had this giant desk
Schwarzenegger assesses that and then to
start the meeting
he goes
what does a little man need such a big
desk
[__] dude lost his
little guy got all mad and he starts
yeah [__] you I'm not gonna use you can
I use you you know he's Italian right
off the boat he goes I cannot use you he
goes you have an accent
and Schwarzenegger goes you have an
accent too
he goes
45 seconds in the history of Hollywood
there's never been a faster meeting
I gotta tell you something man the
[__]
the brains and the balls
on that guy
I mean
I've thought about I thought I I've not
stopped thinking about that how he went
in there
and just
just like
the power that that guy had
it's all it's all dependent on the
person he's talking to giving a [__]
and the fact that Schwarzenegger did not
give a [__] the floor went out from
underneath this little guy and he didn't
know what to do
I'm sure he tried to [__] stop stop
him from
long story short is the guy ended up
producing Conan the Barbarian
and Schwarzenegger was up for the roll
and he didn't want him to get the role
and Schwarzenegger killed it he still
got it
so the little fella comes down to the
set
on one of the days and he watches
Schwarzenegger and Schwarzenegger is
killing it
and he said he walked all the way up the
hill up to me and he just looked at me
and he said you are Conan
the Barbarian
and he walked away
and I was thinking yeah I know him I
have the world
Dude that [__] ice cold logic
all right the only time I ever heard it
like that was when I was in Finland
there's something you get into a part of
[__] Europe
I don't know
what the background is for that mindset
but it is it is astounding when you run
into it
just [__] straight facts
or whatever but just like
I got such it was so inspiring
because I've seen a ton of people
pretending like they don't give a [__]
but like to believe in yourself
to that level
I don't even know what I then I'm
thinking well maybe he just went in
there and he was so competitive
that he was actually like
legitimately asking
why does a little guy need such a big
desk like he was trying to figure him
out like what are you doing
you know with your little socks and
shoes over there and your little pants
like why do you need this big [__]
desk
did it like Intrigue him it's gonna
torture me for the rest of my life
was he was he straight up [__] with
the guy or was he did it not add up you
know like a cop on the beat for [__]
25 years it just doesn't make sense
doesn't add up and he stopped you know
Colombo he comes back you know it's just
one more thing why why is era as a
little fellow way God says why welcome
away you got such a big desk
um
and then when the guy got mad he didn't
even flinch
and [__] beat him in point
Counterpoint it was just
I'm telling you
you got to watch the thing I remember
everybody used to make fun of him too
when he would drive around in the
Hummers none of us knew that he was in
the Army in Austria and was a tank
driver
used to drive around a tank with a
[__] cigar hanging out of his mouth I
mean the guy is just like I don't know
what
it's unreal you become like you just
just watch the [__] thing
after the strike after the strike am I
actually I'm not allowed to promote any
projects but I'm not in that one but I
would tell you I watched that [__]
thing and it's like all right
I'm not gonna get on a [__]
elliptical tomorrow
I throw the weights around a little bit
you know I finally given in to my age I
just take low weight and I just do High
Reps
I work all the muscle groups I have a
picture in my mind that I'm willing my
body
I just have his [__] voice in my head
I have to watch that episode again
do you know when somebody just does
something so cool like you wished you
did it
you know
and then do you start fantasizing that
you actually did it that [__] was so
[__] cool
I wish I did it but I can't I can't even
trick my own mind
and thinking that I would ever do
something that is cool as that
guy's a immigrant
brutal accent could barely speak the
[__] language and goes in there and
just [__] pants
deep pants is this [__] guy
I would have given anything in the world
after he said that to see that little
guy's face and his [__] agent
his agent trying to because this agent
wasn't just worried about his client
there he was like this motherfucker's
not going to meet any of my clients
after this one
and that I'm not gonna lie to you that
reminds me of buddy of mine a comedian
pitched a show at [__] CBS a long
[__] time ago and CBS was a
notoriously
cold room
and he went in there and
it was funny they were being [__]
and he was an [__] and he couldn't
handle basically meeting himself and he
[__] imploded
and just verbally abused all of them and
[__] walked out to the point I was
managed by the same guy and we had to
beg them to let me come in there so I
could go in there and I [__]
I didn't curse him out or anything I
just sat I put on my top hat and Kade
and did my little dance and they just
[__] stared at me
uh it was one of those pitch meetings
you just you had to like
you didn't have to walk it off it was
just so bad you went out to the parking
lot and just laughed like I was like all
right
it didn't even hurt because
there was you could feel there was no
hope even just walking in there so and
that happened to me a lot
so just seeing Schwarzenegger go walking
in on one of his first ones
and to [__] ask that question oh my
God it was just like
poetry
absolute poetry
um
anyway
I was really [__] excited about how
those sets went this weekend and I kind
of have more material than I know what
to do with
which is not a feeling I've had in a
while so
um
I mean I even have a hand job joke that
I didn't even [__] do
oh speaking of which look at this hang
on a second
that's funny I put you guys on hold that
was my agent calling me
who I was like cursing out
to myself when I was standing outside
about ready to do that [__] show in
the park going what am I [__] Paul
Simon the [__] is he booking me this
[__] out here
is Garfunkel going on in front of me
what the [__] are we doing
am I sharing the bill with Peter Paul
and Mary there and then I went up and it
was awesome so I'm gonna tell them
when he calls me back because he did the
classic I pick up the phone hello and he
goes ah [__] can I call you right back
all right
um
anyway so if you get a chance if you get
a chance
um
and then I have to be I'm not gonna lie
to you man the stuff about his brother
Arnold's brother is absolutely
[__]
heartbreaking and it's the kind of story
that like uh
I mean I just like
people not understanding
like sensitive kids
um is just [__] one of the most
heartbreaking things you could ever
[__]
witness or hear about
and uh
I don't know what it is about sensitive
kids I think that they're viewed as weak
and and back in the day I think like
parents had like this
like they took on took it on and felt
like you know
I don't have weak kids I have strong
sperm I just make [__] Warriors and
they don't realize that there's all
these different ways of being struck
oh God there's a couple of stories that
Arnold tells men oh my God they're
[__] heartbreaking but it's an
incredible
oh I would I would kill to listen any of
those tapes Hey Arnold we're gonna we'll
get you some small rolls and uh you know
uh use some character actor stuff that's
how open and he's like [__] [__]
I'm doing those stupid [__] parts
I want to be the star
and then listening to
listening to the going like how the [__]
am I going to make you a star when you
talk like that
I'm not gonna say [__]
bigger than my head I mean that must
have been the like
somebody says it in the documentary says
he is the most incredible career of
anybody ever I mean I as far as like
where he came from what he sounded like
and what he ended up doing it's just
[__] it blows I know I'm going on and
on about we get it Bill we get it
we understand it we're gonna check it
out
um
all right well guess what I just
finished four [__] weekends in
a row
four weekends in a row Oh Billy has the
rest of the month off tell me what you
gonna do Billy Boy Billy Boy tell me
what you gonna do Charming Billy
I'm gonna swim with my kids play some
drums and fly a helicopter because I
don't give a [__] cause I wrapped up
when I was in Edmonton
standing out in the park talking about
my dick
um
I want to get a
I'm gonna do like three
long flights
this week
that's what I want to do and I'm going
to take a little drum lesson
have a cup of coffee and then I'm
hanging out with my kids and that's my
thing if you guys are parents I'm
telling you right now this is what you
do during summer vacation
all right you just every single day like
I am doing something with my kids
all right you do it in the morning so
you you did it it's not hanging over
your head you don't feel guilty if you
[__] go out and sit in a cafe and try
and practice French for the umpteenth
millionth time
um and you think I gotta get home
because I gotta [__] do it you did it
it's like going to the gym go to the gym
[__] get rid of goddamn blubber oh my
God I finally stepped on the scale oh
Jesus Christ
after two weeks of going to the gym I
was still a buck 86. all right I need to
be like 168 172.
and I've only been like 190 a couple
times in my life 190 191 it was all
during like covet so I don't even want
to know what my [__] weight was if I
lost a couple two three pounds each I
think I was kind of at my heaviest
so I was hoping it was going to be low
180s
so uh but I did it you know I was
avoiding the scale
you know but I was such a fat [__] that
even like losing a little bit of weight
I was looking in in the mirror and I was
like all right you know looking all
right now let's talk about
it might be
179.8 step on the scale
I don't want to step with this kill just
step on the scale
just get the information and I went over
and I stepped on the [__] that's
another problem that I had
a long time ago if you go back on my
podcast I said you got to weigh yourself
every [__] day so it doesn't get out
of control and I knew it was getting out
of control and I and I broke my own Rule
and instead of just putting on five
pounds I put on like [__] north of
20.
like the stupid bald freckled [__] that
I am so now
I don't know I'm just uh
I'm just going every day
I actually had a meal I had a berry
salad and Brussels sprouts
and I was eating it and I actually felt
great afterward
I kind of go back and forth with that
vegetarian [__] but I've also been
eating meat so I wasn't like
I tried this a long time ago I was like
you know I'm saying I have one
vegetarian meal a day
why don't I do that
you know why because it's hard
that's why it's because it requires me
to make an FME go out and go like go get
some chicken or or beef or something I
know where to go for that
I don't want to start all over again
it's like learning a language I already
know how to speak what
I don't want to try to learn another one
like I'm [__] two years old
um
but I will say
when you do live like that
eat a little bit less or whatever I have
gotten myself though I don't [__] with
potato chips I don't eat cookies I just
say it out loud I just go I don't eat
that stuff
I don't eat that stuff
what'd you say I I don't eat that stuff
you get a [__] problem
um
yeah I don't eat desserts
I don't eat [__] potato I'm not even
gonna have [__] cake on my birthday
you know
I'm not five years old
like why why am I having a [__] piece
of cake
I'll tell you why because it's [__]
delicious
that's a Line in the Sand
you know
with fatties cake up pie
I mean morbidly obese people just say
yes
you know what I mean they're like the
porn stars
of food eaters like they have a
threesome
you know where everybody else is like
well you know of course sort of you know
what do they call it monogamous
I have cake or pie
and they're like no I want both
would you like a candy bar or some ice
cream yes
cut it up stick it in there freeze it up
and I'll [__] inhale it
it's amazing man it's like
they're food stories it's like listening
to Keith Richards tell stories about
being on tour in the [__] 70s except
rather than like smack and Coke
it's it's it's it's [__] food
you know
I'm not really trashing fat people right
now as much as I'm missing what I was
eating that got me this fat
[Laughter]
you're a bald Ginger you're gonna add
fat to that you're gonna be a fat bald
redheaded male you you think that the
world is going to come to you after that
you you us you are sadly mistaken or is
it sorely
sadly or sorely mistaken I don't I don't
I don't know exactly what the
terminology is
but um
not for me anyway so we are in the dog
days of July Dog Days of baseball right
um
I'm gonna watch some baseball when I'm
home all of a sudden I'm starting to see
people you know they're starting to hint
that football's right around the corner
what about that can you believe it
do you believe it I'm [__] excited
the Bruins re-signed Milan lucich
right
I haven't heard anything about Bergeron
I got a feeling he's done he's going to
retire what a [__] career
you know his name's on the cup
it's one of the great centers of all
time
and human beings so I figure it becomes
uh crazy you'll probably retire too and
then I think it becomes Brad marchand's
team
you know
maybe he wears the C I don't know how it
works but I'm looking forward to it
and I'm not worried about last
you know
last year I wouldn't even call it a
collapse because I don't believe in the
regular season
you know like it's this you know if you
[__] crushed a regular season you
know if you're beating the [__] out of a
lot of these teams that aren't even
going to be there
really doesn't mean anything does it
um I remember the last time we had this
level of a heartbreaking loss
was when we got swept by the Flyers
after we had won three games and we
didn't swim we lost four straight after
winning three straight
we were like oh my god what the [__]
and uh
the very next year we won the cup so I'm
hoping that that's going to happen
I'm hoping that that's gonna happen all
right let's do some dad talk I have to
tell you uh we've been all me and my two
kiddos every single day have been in the
pool except these last two because I was
on the road but every single I already
came home
and I was like I said to my daughter I
was like I gotta do my podcast and she
was just like oh I was like all right
let's go to the pool first do the pool
first
right
work before play
or play before work whatever it is
responsibility right so
it is the most fun thing I've ever I
think I've done with my kids so far
as much as riding bikes with them is fun
there's something about being in a pool
everybody's smiling and laughing and I
just love looking at my son like
he's such a good swimmer already because
he's he's looking at his older sister
like he comes up from under the water
and immediately smiles to look to see
where she is and what she's doing and
then he wants to do it and uh
I got great hugs from them when I came
home
it's funny my son is is so like
like testosterone you know
climbing up on stuff and having little
temper tantrums and throwing his toys
and stuff
but when I come home he's such a little
sweetheart
he goes dada
dada and he's like hugging me kisses the
my like my nose
[Music]
and he's like that for like 90 seconds
and then I set him down and then that's
it takes off
and goes and destroys the house
but you know he's young he'll grow out
of it all right let's do the uh let's do
the reads here
um
all right oh Simply Safe everybody you
know when an intruder threatens your
home every second counts it's why I am
so excited to tell you about the latest
Innovation from Simply Safe home
security it's called 24 7 live guard
protection and it's made possible only
by simply safe's new Smart Alarm
Wireless indoor camera
well let's make sure I hope this isn't
the same system that was watching that
guy from [__] Epstein Island
um now
[Laughter]
oh it magically shut up now with the
fast protect monitoring plan
if an intruder breaks into your home
Simply Safe monitoring agents can
actually see speak to and deter them
through the camera
warning them that they're being recorded
and that the police are on their way
it's a game changer in home security
that is unfucking believable
that is unbelievable
they're going to be in the home base hey
you with the ax
stay away from that bedroom
24 7 live guard protection and the new
Smart Alarm indoor camera Works
seamlessly as part of the entire Simply
Safe security system
to keep your whole fit your whole
your whole home safe sorry from
break-ins fires flooding and more with
SimpliSafe professional monitoring costs
under a dollar a day a bargain for the
peace of mind it provides right now my
listeners get a special 20 off any
Simply Safe system when you sign up for
fast protect monitoring this huge offer
is for a limited time visit
simplysafe.com that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com slash birth
there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
who do we got next oh look who it is
everybody it's all zip
grow it up
you know if you're hiring you're
currently dealing with economic
uncertainty and now more than Abba it's
important to hire the right people
faster and more efficiently to keep
overall costs down thankfully there's a
hiring partner who is focused on you and
your needs zip recruiter from pricing to
technology everything that zip recruiter
does is for you and what works best for
you and right now you can try them for
free at ziprecruiter.com
here's how ZipRecruiter priority need
prioritizes your needs find great
candidates fast at zip
smart technology identifies the best
matches for your job beat out the
competition
for talent zip
um lets you invite candidates you really
want to apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them hire the best
with the help of a partner that's all
about you zip yes
four to five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day just go to this
exclusive web address to try zip
ah
dot com slash burp that again that's
ziprecruiter.com spell it out z i p r e
c uh sorry
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
come to Japan
is the first
email of the week
do you know I was just talking
says some friends of mine about this
do you know way back in the day
it's one of the most brutal things I
ever saw 60 Minutes was doing something
on the work culture in Japan
now this was like in the 1970s or 80s
and this [__] guy this guy
Japanese dude
in Japan working for a Japanese company
run by Japanese people right
he messed up at work somehow
and his whole family
was like
disappointed lost face whatever they
call call it so he had to get back in
The Graces the good graces of the CEO of
the company and I swear to God he walks
into the room after they they like tried
to reprogram them whatever
and he [__] had to sing like the
company song or something and he's
singing this song to these four people
that are sitting at this desk completely
expressionless and he's like [__]
crying
sitting in the company [__] song
and I had not thought I just remember
thinking like oh my God why like the guy
still wants to work he worked there like
how much you got to humiliate this dude
right
so I don't know why last night that
somehow popped into my head
I don't even know why I popped in my
head and I was telling the story
remembering it now just how crazy then
somebody from Japan writes in come to
Japan okay first of all I would [__]
love to go to Japan
I would love to go over there it looks
unbelievable
dear bill would you ever consider coming
to Japan I have for like 10 years I've
been trying to figure out
a time in my schedule that would work I
have kids now so it's difficult but I
would 100 percent
go there one of the great experiences in
my life was going
on a tour that led that went through
Asia
and seeing
I don't know the food the people
the pop culture the fashion all of that
was incredible literally the other side
of the planet I would love to this
person says I think you'd appreciate our
way of life there's a great respect for
cleanliness and efficiency oh you speak
in my language our food is great and the
city has a lot to offer bring your
family
thanks from Kyoto
first of all I can't believe that you're
all the way over in Japan and you you
listen to this podcast so thank you for
listening to it and uh who doesn't want
to go to a country that's has a great
respect for cleanliness and efficiency
I mean half the [__] I lose my mind
about has to do with that
when I'm walking around the house you
know
someone says they're going to do the
dishes and then you know you go to take
one of the dishes off the dish rack and
there's still a film on it because they
did a half-assed job I didn't want to
talk about it
picking up your side of the [__] room
you know
um I would love to go over there I know
my wife would love to go maybe there's a
way
during a Break
um
when my daughter has a break from school
my son has a break we could figure out a
way to go over there
um
yeah that would be that's kind of a
bucket list one
you know I want to go to Japan I want to
go to South America Brazil or Colombia
or something go down there I want to see
a motorcycle race down there
um
still never been to Africa
I don't know there's there's a lot of
places I would love to see
all right therapy talk
oh Jesus here we go
therapy talk by the way my agent never
called me back
can I call you right back
um therapy talk hey Bill have you heard
this new trend emerging where people
talk to strangers friends and families
as if they're in a therapy session oh
God are you talking about me
I think therapy is great for some but
for most it's just a way to fill their
narcissistic needs yes sometimes
it's that sometimes it's because of
childhood trauma they don't have
boundaries and they just [__] open up
to anybody
um
yeah I saw somebody do that the other
day in a shoe store
the [__] person was asking their shoe
size next you know the person was
talking about how they grew up without a
father
sounds awful anyway uh
what color are you looking for um can we
talk about me for an hour this is what
this person says for the narcissistic
people sure if you have something real
to work out but all these people going
and talking about how to deal with stuff
at work or their stupid friends drama
are just wasting time talking about the
same [__] week every week Justice
stretch the problem out and beat a dead
horse
now they're bringing it to the streets
and wasting my day and the dumb couch
talk I work with the woman who
interjects this stuff into conversation
about the shipping and receiving
department dig a hole and crawl in you
put in it you [__] all right
as much as you're making uh good points
here you kind of seem like you got some
issues too
I actually relate to because that's what
I
used to think when I would listen to
people open up emotionally and you're
100 right I don't want to hear about you
know you got [__] touch funny
by the birthday clown in the [__] 70s
when you know was sitting there digging
a ditch like I don't need to hear that
I'm
you know
I think ugh
she's a woman and she's at work can you
say anything to that in
oh look who decided to call back hang on
a second hang on one second hang on one
sec
yeah so anyway
as I was saying you know you got to be
careful with women in the workplace they
kind of they're holding Four Aces so
um
Jesus Christ what the [__] do you do
with somebody like that
why don't you just say yeah I know you
already told me that
yeah I know yeah I know he diddled you
and it upset you it makes sense that you
would be upset but like you know
we're trying to ship out these [__]
packages here before uh next Valentine's
Day what do you say there toots you want
to give me a hand here you want to grab
a tape gun and help [__] wrap these
things up here what are we doing
oh
you know what dude I I don't know what
to tell you I don't know what the [__]
to do with that but I I I I feel your
your pain with that
I unders I I actually feel both people's
pain yeah I understand why that woman is
doing that because she had never got the
love of whatever she needed and now
she's just like this open faucet of
anybody that listens to her
they just puke out their [__]
childhood
um
you know what I say to people like that
I go you should do some mushrooms
you should do some money oh yeah I heard
about that yeah look it up look it up
so like what what is that yeah listen
listen it's it's your own thing man
it's literally like
learning how to do stand-up comedy I
could tell you a million [__] things
none of it's gonna help you you just
need to get on the stage and do it
you could talk to me
I can talk to you doing blue and face
about mushrooms just
go do it
go do it all right
and uh just
to be you know safe here uh a shaman is
not a white guy in yoga pants
hahaha
that's all the advice I have for you
um
God now you got me thinking about that
stuff how the [__] do you get out of
that when someone is just like opening
up I don't know how to exist in the job
world anymore because I left it
in like 95.
so when in 1995 you'd be like oh my God
will you shut up about your [__]
childhood and then she would cry
and then people like come on man and
then you go over and you would apologize
and you know that was it you're taking a
friendlies you get a fribble and that
was it you didn't lose your [__]
career over it so I don't know
um yes I did say friendlies and a
fribble you take it a Rocky Point uh
broke up with the girl cause of Red
Rocks
oh no Billy bruschetta
your woman supporting women bit on Red
Rocks was stellar
well thank you that was uh
that was that was a fun joke to tell I'm
one of the four kids I'm one of four
kids and the only boy my sisters are
awesome at Sports and have competed
through high school and college I
respect them as athletes however I agree
with you when it comes to the points you
made hey hey hey hey let's not hear this
[__] thing wrong here all right I was
not [__] on female athletes I was
[__] on all the women who don't show
up and support them
all right and is it and like
when female athletes complain about
their pay they're yelling at men like I
don't understand why they're like ladies
where are all the feminists come on out
to the [__] game
come out and watch us play the way the
men come out and watch the men play
right
which I'll be honest man there's a
[__] WNBA game on I watch it I
[__] enjoy it
I enjoy women's softball volleyball on a
bunch of different levels
I will watch that show
that [__] most women
I watch the [__] so I mean I don't know
I I like to think I'm an ally
uh except for volleyball I'm kind of a
perv uh I was dating a girl up until
this week we had been together since
March and really got off to a great
start recently we started engaging in
more debate and conversation
uh a month ago we watched Red Rocks and
both laughed when it came to the WNBA
bit she liked it but said it was based
on a male's perspective
well yeah I mean she's right I'm a male
I like to think I am Jesus I asked what
you got wrong and she said his attitude
I said his attitude isn't a fact you may
not like the way he said it
but what he said isn't wrong
we disagreed but it wasn't a big deal
because I'm tolerant of people's stupid
opinions
was that a joke on purpose or accidental
brilliant comedy
wasn't a big deal because I'm tolerant
of people's stupid oh he says joke but
also I'm chill with this stuff
all right you know something
just that sentence alone I can tell as I
used to say back in the day in Boston
you're a hot [__] so I'm starting to
lean to your side in this argument cut
to two weeks ago I asked her if she
wanted to go to my sister's playoff game
she's been to a couple of games with me
in the past and she liked him twist I
have a male cousin in the state finals
for a different sport that she [__] that
she's friends with
uh that game was going to be huge and
everyone in town was going she said she
wanted to go to the boys game because it
was going to be a huge event this was my
opening I didn't want to argue I just
hated the way she just dismissed your
bit it was
fronting about being a feminist and now
she was proving your point
please tell me you you waited to bring
this up until after she went to the mail
person's game anyways he says she wasn't
having it I asked her why not support
the girls team because their stands
would be more empty and made all the
obvious
parallels she couldn't comprehend the
hypocrisy we broke up when she said she
she wouldn't admit that you were right
wow I might be getting laid a little
less this summer but at least I'm a man
of principle right right he says thanks
and go [__] yourself
um
I'm gonna tell you something sir you're
gonna do just fine in life in the most
important area of finding love
all right
a lot of guys
once they get a hold of someone you know
they get afraid to leave and blah blah
the fact that you were fine with letting
her go on something like that
you know there was a lot in that
there's a lot in that she didn't seem
like she was playful
she didn't seem like she could take
responsibility make Brandon this is just
your your side of it but the way you
described it
is you know
relationships are [__] hard so you
have to be like malleable you know what
I mean
you can't just be like you know when you
met me in 2006 that's what I thought and
you're like so [__] think so [__] you
you can't do that you gotta you know
there's gotta be give and take and that
type of stuff and it kind of seems like
that's what you were looking for and you
didn't get it and you walked
that's great
all right
I really believe you got you got to
marry somebody
that has a great sense of humor and can
laugh at themselves and can apologize if
they did something wrong
all right and then conversely you have
to give them those gifts too and if the
two of you guys can do that you got a
shot but if you're gonna be [__]
you know
she could have just [__] queued it
away through that all right you're right
well that's gonna be more exciting when
I do that then you would laugh
and you guys would have had a great
[__] time
but instead she died on the hill
um
oh God help the poor bastard that ends
up with that
another male perspective all right world
war three oh Jesus
we're going [__] deep here
we're going deep into the goddamn Weeds
on this one all right let's see here
dear General Burr
let's get right into it please how do
you feel about a world war or the
ridiculous people forcing us to consider
if they're going to [__] us into a World
War
um I have to be honest with you I don't
[__] pay attention
to any of this [__]
okay I just I just I don't pay attention
to it because it was bad enough when it
was happening when I was a kid
but at least I was listening to
intelligent people
on TV
and I know they were still part of a
corporate news thing and I know that
they were talking heads and that type of
stuff but I didn't have to listen to
every mouth breathing [__] [__]
um
who just
can't see the trees through the forest
doesn't know history
but they have a mouth and they can speak
English and I I just I can't [__] do
it so anyways okay president putting
brains
I mean which one are you talking about
ours are theirs or whoever is running
the country
are pushing for war not peace
leaked messages show US military talking
about how the war is unwinnable for
Ukraine but we keep sending money
150 000 Ukrainian men and women have
been killed in battles they have no
chance in winning
there were peace agreements almost in
place but NATO's slash Biden's
Administration sent the UK's Boris
Johnson to speak to zielinski and force
him out of them
all right so now and then he has a link
here
so now I'm supposed to read this and
here's the source all right let me click
on the source here
this is so above my pay grade another
NATO Ally confirms U.S block peace in
the Ukraine what website is this
like how do you tell what you're reading
is [__] real or it's written by
somebody from Russia I don't know they
said Putin couldn't be negotiated with
even though he has
and they were doing so and they also
said the West wasn't done with its
involvement
can't wash money without a war
I like to point out some of the [__]
U.S taxpayers are going to be funding
the rebuild of the Ukraine it'll be
financed by JP Morgan and BlackRock the
loans will be paid by us there's another
source all right
I like this person just not saying this
actually has sources
no one cares about fixing America Tucker
Carlson asked presidential candidate
Mike Pence why he cares more about
getting tanks and Munitions to the
Ukraine than helping everyday Americans
pointing out the major problems in
American cities he said it's not my
concern and went on to what talk about
geopolitical [__]
remember during the Iraq War Phil
Donahue was fired for questioning
wmd's and they fired him despite having
the highest rated show on CNN
well they did that to Tucker Carlson a
few months ago for questioning this war
again despite all the money he was
making Fox News as the highest rated
show in late night it was more important
to keep everyone stupid yeah
and guess what bill I can find a problem
with this without having Tuckers without
having Ben Tucker's number one fan
well I'm not a fan of that guy but
that's a great [__] question I'm glad
he had the balls to ask it
I'm not a fan of anyone on CNN or Fox
News I just think they're all
like just they're just
they're just all terrible people
[Laughter]
and they are
just leading us down this [__] hell
hole
and as long as they get a nice [__]
house out of it they evidently don't
give a [__] uh anyway cue all the dopes
who want to shout Putin apologist
at their phones
I love name-calling
Putin apologist trumpster
[__] libtard Centrist
what kind of an adult gives a [__]
about name-calling
Putin apologists at their phone they're
idiots who don't understand history or
have any world view outside of cable
news they're the same ones who called
people terrorist sympathizers back when
you questioned going after a country
that had nothing to do with 9 11.
yeah look what that bankrupted our
country for some reason they're blaming
Joe Biden like no one remembers like
dude we went over there we've been over
there it cost like a billion dollars a
day we're out of money
we've been bankrupt
uh I feel sorry for your freckled ass
always being discredited for saying both
sides and being a Centrist to sell
tickets because you're right thanks for
being a sane voice well yeah
I appreciate that I like what you said
could you complimented me
yeah that whole thing where you have to
uh they don't they don't feel like
listening to people
is also a side
you know what I mean you got to be there
so you got to be that it's like no I
don't and I don't have to think any
[__] thing that you think and and
like
I will 100 disagree with somebody I'll
listen to you
you know I mean I call people names I do
say mouth breed mormonal but I I
wouldn't
I mean I do it like on the podcast right
this is me justifying me being a mouth
breathing [__] um anyway all right this
is this is the podcast everybody
I mean like it or not this is what I do
um all right so
uh
let's wrap it up here what if we learned
I had a great time in Tacoma in Edmonton
I still cannot [__] believe
how great that coffee was how great
Tacoma was and how great that outdoor
gig was in Edmonton it was absolutely
perfect
and uh the highlight of the weekend was
hanging out last night with Nate Craig
and Bianca christophile
and me and Nate got her to sing the
Czech uh national anthem was [__]
amazing because we were in Canada and me
and Nate were trying to remember the
[__] Canadian National Anthem and
she's from uh Czech Republic
and uh yeah it was just one of those
[__]
silly nights man it was [__] awesome
I I could not have it up at a time all
right so thank you to everybody that
showed up to my shows thank you
everybody that continues to show it to
my shows thank God you do that because
my entire
business that I am is I'm in is shut
down right now so uh you guys are
saving my ass here thank you so much
and go [__] yourselves can I really end
that way
that's how I sign off oh Jesus bill I'll
talk to you on Wednesday how Thursday
sorry about that